And as for Mcculloch technologies I will
be resuming my position as CEO
effective immediately
it's what Joseph would have wanted
Thank you
Oh, Joe!
How are you here. Well it turns out that
when the guy that's trying to kill you
kicks the bucket they lift the
protection detail. That make sense - hey man!
yeah
And just in time team needs you now more
than ever
well let's go save some people we love
You have been at this for hours Barry
wouldn't give up and the woman that he
married wouldn't either
I found him David's at Central City
Hospital I can't believe I just did that
holy frak iris you can control this
place
Iris
Iris stay with me
Hey ah
you gonna clean that or
what?
any day now any day now come on
Cinderella scrub like you mean it.
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my flash episode 19 ending
video for the finale and the flash
season 7 teaser there's a couple things
that obviously they had to push to the
beginning of season 7 because they
canceled the last couple of episodes
because of what happened with the virus
so we'll break it all down if you're new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos we're doing an Amazon
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave all your
predictions for the flash season 7 so
we'll just number these as we go along
I'll start with the original stuff that
they had planned to do for the finale
like that funny clip of reverse-flash
there was a big big reverse flash moment
that they were going to end on according
to Grant Gustin and if you see the last
couple of big flash videos that I've
done it's all about his negative Speed
Force energy just dissipating into the
atmosphere and waiting for another body
to find to inhabit then take over so
that he can manifest again in the
physical world most of us believe that
was going to lead up to a Red Death
teaser because the whole idea of the
fusion speedster we're talking about
dragonball tropes here talking about
Gogeta versions of the flash the whole
idea that last big reverse flash arc is
that he no longer has a physical body he
needs to steal a body from someone else
and that's kind of what happens with Red
Death in the comics it's a fusion of
batman and barry allen's flash we heard
that there was a version of Red Death
inside the arrowverse in the future
episode with Nora during season 5
episode 18 we don't know when he
appeared in the timeline only that it
was in Nora's past because it was the
flash Museum that they talked about him
so it's at some point after season 6
but before Nora became a speedster but
we don't know whose body he's going to
steal now there are a lot of people that
thought that it might be bloodwork's
body because he kept talking about
conquering death he just kept mentioning
death every single time he was on screen
I'm going to cure death I'm going to stop
people from dying there are wolves
beyond baseball
I was never going to just walk out of here
but there's more than one way of me to
be free let's just call this the long
game but whoever it winds up being the
TV show's version of red death is not
going to be like the comic book red
death because there's no way they're
going to do a version of Batman in the
arrowverse like this we got a version of
Batman during crisis but that was just
very brief so there's a big limitation
on what they can do with the Batman
character even though a comic book
authentic Red Death would be amazing it
would be great if there was an evil
version of Bruce wayne/batman that had
become the Red Death somewhere out there
the funny clip of the reverse-flash
just cleaning the wall with elongated
man that joke clip that's actually from
a couple episodes ago
even when reverse-flash eventually takes
over someone's body he wouldn't be
wearing his yellow reverse flash costume
manifesting in the physical world but
because that was meant to be the
post-credits scene for the original
finale in a big season 7 teaser is just
implied that we'll find out what was
going on with that for real during the
first half of season 7 along with all
the stuff that they had to cancel
because of the virus so we lost episode
20 21 in 22 I didn't necessarily expect
them to wrap up the godspeed plot in the
next couple of episodes that seemed like
more of a season 7 teaser that they were
setting up who is the real version of
godspeed behind all these fake
cybernetic versions of Godspeed sending
them into the past based on their last
scene in that episode
it sounded like it's the real August
heart in the future and he's just using
these cybernetic copies to steal speed
from other people using that special
technique then give it to himself
remember this is whole storyline with
the Speed Force slowly dying a lot of
people were like well where did Goths be
get his speed from well he was stealing
it from other speedsters like he's stole
a bunch of speed from Barry during the
episode but because they're doing all
this blackhole stuff and they're doing a
lot more villains from flash rebirth the
Godspeed arc in flash rebirth eventually
ties in with the whole other villain
from the future called paradox he's a
relatively new addition to the DC Comics
canon so if you haven't heard about him
don't worry they haven't said whether or
not they're going to do him on the TV show
he is a strong link to the origin story
of the Barry Allen flash but his powers
basically give him a connection to the
Speed Force in the time stream so they
could also wind up doing paradox in the
future too and he
be another big villain behind Godspeed
but right now they're still building up
to the real version of Godspeed so they
would do that first before they do the
paradox character then there's the big
teaser about Barry trying to create the
artificial Speed Force with Cisco using
the perpetual motion device that's why
he left in last week's episode and the
reason why he wasn't in the finale
because he's still in Atlantis getting
the last piece that he needs to build
that perpetual motion device we don't
know what's going on with Aquaman on
earth prime but because we have a
version of Superman we've had a version
of Batman on the show we've had famous
Kira Atlantis is just the next step in
building up two more big Justice League
characters inside the arrowverse but
because of Jason Momoa as Aquaman movie
franchise they're probably not going to be
doing quite as much Aquaman stuff on the
TV shows the only reason why they're
able to get away with so much Superman
and the Superman TV show is because they
weren't in the middle of developing
another Henry Cavill Superman movie when
all this stuff was going on even though
there is talk about them doing more
Superman in the movies really soon so in
terms of Aquaman on the TV shows my
expectation right now is that they'll
just tease the idea of Atlantis then
we'll find out about an Arthur curry
Aquaman in the background then
eventually in some future season of
maybe the Superman TV show we'll see
that actual version of Aquaman show up
if you're not going to do an actual Aquaman
on the flash TV show then the Superman
TV show would be the logical place to
put him fun fact - if you guys watch
Smallville the person who played Aquaman
on Smallville is the person who's
playing Hawk on Titans right now you'll
know the real big Justice League
character that they haven't done yet in
any kind of way is actually the Wonder
Woman character and that's just because
gal gadot Wonder Woman franchise is
still blowing it up so big when that
search to cool off a little bit then
you'll probably start seeing Wonder
Woman stuff happening on the Superman TV
show but the other big flash season 7
teasers that they leave off in episode
19 are a mere master getting her comic
book Mere masters suit to help her
retain cohesion in the real world she's
still got that weird nervous tic where
she scratches herself that she developed
in the mirror verse she's taken control
of mcculloch tech which also gives her
control of all the black hole and their
assets weapons the metahumans the Carver
had been using like she was controlling
all their versions of the Rogues in that
final big boss fight then there's that
final scene of iris Camilla and Singh
still stuck inside the mirror dimension
which apparently iris can't
control now or interact with in some
more advanced way as a result of
prolonged exposure and now they'll have
to get her out in the beginning of
season seven originally my assumption is
is they would have taken care of this in
episode 22 and that's when they would
have gotten rid of this version of mere
master most of these weird matrix-like
abilities that it seems like she
developed inside the mirror dimension
would be useless in the real world so
part of the reason why I think they gave
her these random abilities is the
foreshadow a showdown with mere master
inside the mirror dimension and they
want to have the iris character be a
more active participant in stopping her
at the end of this mirror master arc
which now is going to be in the first
couple of episodes of season 7 but the
other big thing that they leave on is
the suit did need twist where a mere
master frames her for the death of
Joseph Carver which is why she can't go
home if he didn't see the news they
actually upgraded the actress who plays
sue Disney to a series regular for
season 7 I think that's just to give her
more scenes with elongated man and
they're going to eventually get them
together as a couple somewhere around
the middle of season 7 maybe the back
half of season 7 but what's going to happen
next week is the stargirl TV show is
going to take the Flash's timeslot so stargirl episode 1 will drop next week I
will do a video for that explaining
what's going on with the Justice Society
because it's going to be a different
version of the Justice Society in those
characters like they have a Jay Garrick
flash but it's not the john wesley shipp
Jay Garrick flash the CW also bought the
broadcast rights to the swampthing TV
show from the DC Universe but they're
not doing a season two they're just
going to rebroadcast all the episodes from
Season one so if you've already seen all
the swampthing episodes it won't be
anything new for you everyone post all
your reactions are your big questions
about the flash season 7 in the comments
what will happen is is I'll name a
giveaway winner when I post my next DC
video so everyone click here for my new
Wonder Woman 3 movie video and learn
about the new Man of Steel movie that
they're working on and click here for my
brand new Mandalorian season 2 video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe I'll see you guys tonight!